this is a pepper panic saga level 63
walkthrough tutorial
i'm going to play through the level and
explain how you beat it
it's a tricky level
there's only 12 moves
and
all your statues are over here
so
in order to get to them you have to
clear out the ice
and a lot of times you'll run out of
moves before you can get all the way
over there
there is one pepper that's by the
statues
that you have to explode in order to get
any damage
and we're going to try to do that but at
the same time we're going to try to open
up this area because that's how we can
shoot shock waves at the statues
this is a pretty bad layout in the
beginning
no no big matches to start with so i'm
just going to
rearrange things try to set up a shot
so you see that's what we're trying to
do is we're trying to
explode some peppers to get rid of some
ice but also shoot this area as well
the shock waves have a double you know
they
they grow peppers but then they also
hit the ice directly
all right now that we have a lot of the
ice cleared out we'll try to
either damage this one enough to get
more peppers just to fall
yeah that's that's what we wanted to
have happen there
now now whenever the pepper panic starts
and these peppers get cleared new ones
will take their place
so we still have some purple that are
trapped in ice and that
it's probably gonna make it so that we
can't finish this time
you can see it starts out really
confined and then
it you know things open up pretty
quickly once you get rid of that ice
so the statues all need to hit so
there's really not much chance that we
can
take them out we don't have any shots
here
so i'm just going to go ahead and
explode the purple and see what happens
i don't see anything better as far as
choices
alright so no luck on that one
one of the things that
isn't isn't too bad about this one is it
actually it plays pretty quick so
even though it's it's really frustrating
at times you don't have to
labor over it
so i'm doing the same thing i'm just
taking trying to grow peppers as fast as
possible to clear the ice and taking as
many shots as i can
we got a choice here we have a t or
a vertical
i mean a horizontal um
well we got a bunch of them but let me
go with the t since the blue is the one
inside here and we don't have any damage
on the blue yet
alright so we either want to hit these
statues at the top or explode this one
we don't have any shots down we need to
clear explode another yellow but we
don't have a way of doing that yet so
i'm going to go ahead and take this
double shock wave here
that should start a chain reaction
and uh even so you can see even though
we exploded this purple or this blue one
that was inside here
it really didn't help us out
a ton because now there's no more
peppers down there until we can hit one
of these top statues we're in a pretty
tough spot
and we still have yellows that need to
explode as well and they're in the way
of us making any shockwave matches at
the moment
so i'm going to try to get them opened
up which i did
and um
we have we have five minutes left so
it's not lost at this point but we're
gonna have to hit one of these top
statues
either by luck in this cascade or or set
it up somehow
all right so let's look at our options
we have
nothing great up here
nothing great down here
we have
a vertical one that we can
we can try to set up
and that fell into place for us nicely
so
now we have blue and yellow down here
so we are going to want to explode blue
i'm gonna go ahead and make this this
one here though first because even
though we only have three moves this is
gonna
this is gonna potentially it's gonna
explode a purple it's gonna explode
yellow
and it's gonna potentially clear out
this whole space so new things can
happen inside there
and that wasn't
it wasn't fantastic but
i'm going to go ahead and
go ahead and make this blue match down
here
this this will start a chain reaction
and that'll at least get us this one to
explode
okay so now we have
a similar situation
that we get to approach this a couple
different ways um
we could try to explode the purple
since those are the ones that are
closest to it now
what i'm going to do instead though is
i'm going to explode the blue because
that's going to remove this one from the
bottom
and
we could it'll it'll definitely start a
pepper panic and we may get another blue
that'll be touching the statues
so even though it's not perfect it's uh
i think it's the best of the options
you see a blue one dropped right in
where we wanted to so
the reason you can do that here is
there's only three colors so it's a
pretty good chance that
the color you need is going to fall
so that's how you beat it it's a
it's a frustrating level on a lot of
tries it'll you know you'll get close
and not get it or you won't get anywhere
if you can't clear out the ice in the
beginning
but if you follow the tips from our
guide and take your time at the end to
pick the best matches and whatnot you'll
be able to get past it before too long
hope this helps
thanks